Imagine for a moment that you’ve never
seen a board wipe before. No Wrath of God,
no Blasphemous Act, no Toxic Deluge, and certainly
no Farewell. Alternatively, we can imagine you
have heard of these things, like you’re vaguely
familiar with them, but nobody really plays them
because why would you? That’s not how commander
is played. We can imagine a resulting environment
of decks that commit hard to the board with
no fear of punishment, decks that prioritize
proactive plans and pushing damage rather than
developing slower engines and sculpting a hand.
Players run less ramp, and likely less draw
in some cases as well, because there’s less
of a need to weave that stuff into the rest
of your gameplan, and there’s a heavier focus
on building an unbeatable board of synergistic
nonsense. So let’s say that’s the universe we live
in. Now let’s say somebody casts a Wrath of God.
Everybody’s collections of midrange are wiped out
in one fell swoop. Backup plans are scarce, hands
dwindling in size. Looks of dejection, resentment,
anger even, cross the faces of everybody else at
the table. The unspoken rules have been broken,
the format as it was known by these hypothetical
people thrown on its head with a single card.
Nobody prepared for this, because why would
they? This isn’t how the format is played.
Where am I going with this? Well, one could argue
this is very similar to the relationship the EDH
community has with mass land destruction. Just as
there are ways people mitigate board wipes now,
there are all sorts of ways you could
mitigate the impact of a mass land
destruction spell like Armageddon. You
could play more indestructible lands,
you could diversify your ramp package
with creature and artifact-based ramp,
you could place a heavier emphasis on land
recursion or run Second Sunrise effects,
you could run more extra land play effects and
be careful to keep some lands in hand, and,
you could run lower-curved decks that require less
mana to do effective plays. Mass land destruction
is acutely painful largely because people don’t
prepare for it, and people don’t prepare for it
because it’s not commonly accepted as a major
part of the format. It’s worth keeping in mind
that frequent board wipes being accepted as a fact
of life at most EDH tables isn’t some natural fact
that got plucked out of the ground wholly formed,
and the fact that mass land destruction is mostly
absent from EDH tables isn’t a natural fact
either. The reason why people are frequently
prepared for one and frequently unprepared for
the other comes down to social factors. Now,
does that mean that Armageddon and Wrath of God
are equivalent cards in some objective sense,
sharing a common DNA even if they’re interpreted
differently by the people who play EDH? The answer
to that is more complicated than it seems
and I’ll touch back on this question later,
but I’ll start by exploring the answer that most
players would give you: no, they’re obviously not.
Part 1: Stax
Why aren’t they? Well, lands produce mana,
a fundamental resource required for playing
the game, whereas creatures are just the guys you
hit your opponents with. If creatures are wiped,
players can usually keep casting spells, whereas
if lands are wiped, they often can’t. To bring
a key piece of vocabulary into this, mass land
destruction is a form of Stax. Stax is a broad
category of card with conflicting etymological
claims that I will not be getting into,
but the most basic definition of stax is
that it’s resource denial. A 2013 post on
MTGSalvation’s EDH forum lists 14 cards as the
universal colorless stax package. Of these,
4 remove lands, 4 keep lands or other permanents
tapped down, 3 increase the cost of spells,
and the other 3 perform other effects that are
broadly in line with the rest of these things.
The common theme is that all but one of these
target mana in some way, and it’s also common
to see cards that target card draw among classic
stax pieces. Broadly, a stax deck is one that
looks to restrict the table’s resources, and then
break parity on those restrictions—basically to do
something to everybody, and then play in a way
that isn’t as affected by that thing. Examples
include playing a Winter Orb with a bunch
of mana rocks on board, playing a Smokestack
with a Bitterblossom on board, and playing mostly
creature spells with cards that tax noncreature
spells on board. In common EDH parlance, there
are a number of other things that also fall into
the stax descriptor—cards that prevent players
from casting certain spells, cards that limit
how many spells a player can play, cards that
prevent abilities in some way, and even cards
that prevent players from using their graveyards.
These are also sometimes called “Rule” cards.
The Stax archetype is traditionally all about
denying your opponents the tools they need to
play the game. A Modern deck known as lantern
control is the most distilled version of this
idea—control opposing draws to prevent them from
finding anything useful, prevent the opponent
from attacking with a card known as Ensnaring
Bridge, and then eventually win with incremental
mill or another slow but compact wincon. As Sam of
Rhystic Studies laid out in his video on the deck,
the gameplay goal of the deck was less to win than
it was to prevent the opponent from playing Magic:
the Gathering, to assemble a Rube Goldberg machine
that could prevent the unlucky opponent from
taking any meaningful game action. This amplified
version of things makes it clear why many Stax-y
strategies are taboo in EDH—they are all about
restricting the agency of players. This stands
in contrast to most popular visions for the EDH
format—that it’s a palette to be drawn upon,
a format where more expressive strategies
have room to breathe. This vision of the
format was codified by the RC, rest in
peace, in the cards they chose to ban
and why. Sway of the Stars is banned because it
nullifies all the gameplay that came before it,
making those actions irrelevant. Iona is banned
because it has the potential to lock a whole
player out of casting spells if their deck
is monocolored. A number of other cards are
banned for making agency-denying strategies just
a bit too easy. Whether these bans were deserved
is outside the scope of this video, but they do
indicate a pattern—player agency is important in
EDH. On this much I agree—it’s good when all
players get to play a part in an EDH game,
and it’s never a great feeling when
somebody feels truly left out of a game.
However, over time we as players have developed a
skewed vision of what player agency actually looks
like. “Able to perform meaningful game actions”
is the bar for player suppression when it comes
to Lantern Control, but when it comes to EDH the
definitions are much murkier. We can think about
two different situations in an EDH game as an
example—in situation A, the table is in a soft
lock from a stax player, with a 90% chance of
losing to that player in the next few turns.
In situation B, the table is wildly behind in
resources as compared to an Ur Dragon player,
and has a 90% of losing in the next few turns.
These situations are identical in terms of ability
to perform meaningful game actions—it’s just as
easy to break out of the stax player’s grip as
it is to catch back up to the Ur Dragon player—yet
the first one is generally thought of as the more
objectionable one. One possible reason for this is
that a lot of players seem to think of their deck
more as a fidget toy than as an actual game piece.
You have some sort of synergy thing that your deck
is meant to do, and being able to complete a few
entirely insignificant game actions on your turn,
to scratch that brain itch, registers as a more
positive thing than being able to do nothing at
all. This isn’t some radical observation, but
things get a bit uncomfortable when we consider
that a large portion of commander decks are
snowball midrange in some form or other, decks
with abundant tools to keep getting ahead once
they’re already ahead. Why don’t these violate
conventions of player agency? Shouldn’t decks
give opponents more opportunities to catch back
up? I’ve mentioned excessive counts of “win-more”
cards as a strategic folly in past videos, but
isn’t this deckbuilding choice a bit rude as well?
You can say “just play removal”, but that logic
works equally well for a stax piece like Ward of
Bones as it does for a turbocharged engine like
Chimil the Inner Sun, even as the former is going
to catch you a lot more side-eye than the latter.
As another example, let’s talk about one of
the most agency denying cards that’s widely
played in EDH—Teferi’s Protection. Being
completely disallowed from interacting with
a player in any form for a whole turn cycle is
wildly disempowering. A core feature of Magic:
the Gathering is that there are different axes on
which to attack your opponent—life total can be
hit, noncreature permanents can be knocked
out with removal, and creatures can be hit
either with removal or by forcing blocks. Even if
somebody plays a fog or counters a removal spell,
there is still usually a counterplay that
a prepared player can execute. Not so with
Teferi’s Protection—for three mana, all board
interaction and forms of damaging a player are
shut down until that player’s next turn, with a
counterspell being the only possible option for
counterplay. It’s the sort of effect whose
all-encompassing nature would be valid at
an inflated cost of something like 5 mana, but
instead it’s costed at 3, the same as most board
wipe dodges. You get invulnerability as just a
little-bitty tacked on side benefit. I have a
similar problem with The One Ring—it’s a powerful
draw spell for four mana, it’s indestructible,
and it makes a player invulnerable to most forms
of life loss until their next turn. In both cases,
these are cards with one primary mode, but also
a stapled on effect that dramatically reduces
the number of meaningful game actions opponents
can take. People know these cards are strong,
but I haven’t seen much complaining about
these particular clauses being on these cards,
and it’s not hard to guess the reason
why—these cards don’t restrict the fidget
toy. Opponents can still putter around
inconsequentially with value permanents,
even if they’re about to die to a massive turn
from the Teferi-protected or One Ring-ed player.
What I’m illustrating with these examples is my
biggest issue with the way people talk about Stax,
and really the term Stax itself in the context
of EDH—it does a poor job of describing the thing
people have a problem with, and often excludes
lots of other cards with very similar play
patterns. Looking at the Stax primer from
ten years ago is fascinating, as a number
of the cards listed as stax or stax-adjacent
sound weird to a modern commander player’s brain.
Edicts are once instance of this, and
wraths are another. These may seem like
strange inclusions for a stax-specific guide
given the current dominance of these cards,
but in the context of older eras of commander
and 60 card formats it makes a lot of sense.
It’s accepted as a fact of life now that board
wipes will be lurking around every corner of a
commander game, and that every deck will
have one or more of these sorts of tools,
but most 60 card games feature decks that include
none of these things. Developing a powerful board
in a 60 card format is a genuinely game-winning
proposition, and creatures are useful as tools to
deal damage as opponents, not just as another
permanent type that draws cards or has a cool
ability. Under this previous conceptualization
of the game, wiping a board full of creatures
is ripping away resources from opponents,
in the same way ripping away artifacts is,
or maybe even lands. These aren’t identical, but
the parallels are absolutely there. Another card
type here that echoes back to my frustration
with Teferi’s Protection is defensive cards.
Attacking a player is a game action, and when
a Lantern Control deck runs Ensnaring Bridge,
that is one of the game actions they are
looking to curtail. We can even think about
goad—Maldhound was correct to call it a cousin to
stax, as though it does have the escape valve of
getting less effective once the table is down to a
1v1, it’s still a form of limiting player agency.
All of what I just said is fun theorizing, but
it doesn’t paint a full picture of Stax and what
it means for the EDH format, both as a style of
card and as an archetype. The subject of player
agency naturally dovetails into a strategy that
is very much adjacent to stax—control. Some of you
probably raised your eyebrows at me using Lantern
Control as an example of Stax—it’s right there
in the name! Well, the two strategies are deeply
intertwined—they both care chiefly about the range
of actions opponents are able to take. There are,
however, a handful of commonly cited distinctions
between the two. The most basic distinction is
that stax is predominantly permanent-focused
whereas control is typically instant and sorcery
focused. This is largely true in that the cards
people associate with stax are often permanents
and the cards people associate with control often
aren’t, but this isn’t a distinction that tells
us very much about the game. A more interesting
distinction I’ve heard is that stax is proactive,
whereas control is reactive. This isn’t exactly
true within the context of EDH, but it’s not
true in a very nuanced way that is interesting to
explore, so explore we shall. To start with, when
I say stax is proactive and control is reactive,
what I mean is that stax plays its answers
before problematic spells are cast, whereas
control plays its answers after problematic
spells are cast, often to counter or remove
them. Neither of these styles are considered
proactive in the broader landscape of Magic,
but positioning them as proactive vs reactive in
comparison to each other isn’t an unreasonable
distinction. On a surface level, there is an
undeniable pattern here—a decent portion of
stax pieces are only effective before spells are
cast. Thorn of Amethyst and Rule of Law cannot,
as a point of fact, prevent a spell after it
has been cast—whereas a counterspell can. So
this distinction works on some level, but
it starts to fall apart when we consider
one of the most popular types of stax piece in
commander—permanents that remove abilities. There
are different versions of these in different
colors, but I’m going to use the classics
as our example here—Null Rod, which prevents
artifact ability activations, and Cursed Totem,
which prevents creature ability activations. These
can be both proactive and reactive—you can play
them before a permanent enters, you can play them
after a permanent enters, and you can flash them
in response to a permanent spell if you have
a Shimmer Myr in play. We can even imagine a
player seeing a problematic artifact enter play,
and then casting an Enlightened Tutor in order to
find and play a Null Rod on their next turn. This
stands in contrast to the ever-popular control
tool of counterspells, which can only be cast
in response to a problematic spell, and being
entirely useless to deal with such a card at
any other time. So… which is the proactive one?
A better way to think about these sorts of cards
is in terms of their relationship with resources.
Now, I made the argument earlier that capacity
to deal damage to players is a resource. And I
do believe that! However, it is worth injecting a
bit of nuance into this, because there are useful
distinctions here that shouldn’t be brushed aside
in a fun, quippy little statement. So, I’m going
to separate resources into primary resources and
secondary resources. Secondary resources are what
is directly required to win games, and primary
resources are what is required to get there.
So we can conjure forth in our minds something
that can allow us to win games—a grizzly bear,
let’s say. How can this grizzly bear be rendered
manifest? Well, we need to have the card available
to us to play, physically in our hand, and we
need to have the mana to cast it. So, those
are our two primary resources—cards and mana, with
that mana coming from either a land or some other
source. With this primary and secondary resource
distinction in mind, we can reframe the proactive
vs reactive distinction with regard to stax and
control. Stax is proactive because it attacks
primary resources, the basic building blocks
required for playing the game, whereas control is
reactive because it attacks secondary resources,
the ones required for winning. This makes a lot
of sense when we look at the ability-denying
artifacts I mentioned earlier—the little box
in the bottom right of creatures is what matters
as a secondary resource. The fussy colon-riddled
stuff in the middle of the card is by contrast
more often a primary resource, or at least this
is the pattern among the cards popular in EDH.
If an opponent plays a Vilis, Broker of Blood,
a Cursed Totem will certainly remove a bit of
the utility of the card, but a counterspell or
removal spell is going to be a handier solution
to the problem if getting smashed in the face
by an 8/8 isn’t your idea of a good time. This
framing also comfortably places defensive cards
like Ghostly Prison firmly back in the realm of
being a control tool rather than a Stax tool,
which likely feels more intuitively correct
to a lot of players. So, this updated version
of the proactive vs reactive argument basically
works—in 1v1 formats, that is. In commander
it’s still a bit wrong, and to understand why we
need to talk about what control is trying to do.
In a 1v1 format a control deck is one that
seeks to bring the game to a point of stability,
where an opponent’s capacity to win is in a
managed state, before closing out the game with
some sort of compact wincon. Deck space is split
between cards to manage opposing threats and cards
that allow the control player to gain advantage,
with a smaller portion of deck space spent on
whatever wins the game. This works because
the win isn’t the primary gameplay focus of
the deck—getting to that point of stability is,
survival is. There will be games where a control
player fails to establish enough advantage
pieces or lets their life total drop too low,
and under these circumstances a loss can still
occur once the game has stabilized to some degree,
but these are largely the exception. Broadly,
survival is the name of the game when a control
deck is facing a faster deck. One reason this is
the case is that aggressive decks don’t build in
a bunch of card draw and ramp, because doing
such a thing would be wasteful. You only need
enough resources to reduce your opponent’s life
total to 0, and an additional beater or removal
spell to help push through damage is usually a
better choice than a draw engine. In commander,
though, this is entirely different. All decks
run ramp and draw engines because there’s 120
health among opponents rather than 20, meaning
that scrappy, low-to-the-ground strategies just
don’t pan out as well. As a result, control decks
in EDH can’t necessarily rely on survival alone
to win a game. One way this manifests is in
more powerful wincons—usually combos at higher
powers—but another is that targeting resources
is essential for a control deck in EDH. It’s
near-impossible to fully stabilize if a bunch of
faster decks are able to keep their value engines,
and powerful mana enhancers can likewise pose
a problem. Being a control deck in EDH pretty
much always means hating out opposing sources of
cards and mana—that’s just how the game is played.
All of this to say, control and stax in EDH exist
in a much more tangled and messy relationship than
they do in 60 card formats, bleeding into
one another with their roles and mostly
differentiable through superficial differences
and culturally understood indicators. You could
say that control targets mana less frequently
than stax, and that is true, but doing so isn’t
even solely the domain of these suppressive
decks. As I mentioned earlier, board wipes
are commonplace in EDH, and these frequently
destroy mana in some form or other—things
that wipe creatures remove mana dorks, things
that wipe artifacts destroy mana rocks,
and things that destroy enchantments destroy land
enchantments. Is this just an unfortunate side
effect? Are players shedding a tear every time
they incidentally demolish some opposing mana
production? Stop and genuinely ask yourself,
how many players would run Vandalblast if it
didn’t destroy cards with mana abilities?
I’m willing to bet the answer is a whole
lot less than 16% of all EDH decks with red
in them. We all have the blood of a thousand
slaughtered primary resource generators on our
hands, whether we happen to be a stax player,
a control player, or any other sort of player.
You might be thinking, well that’s just the cost
of playing ramp—but it’s not. Rampant Growth is
the same rate as most mana rocks and it doesn’t
get destroyed by artifact wipes. Green ramp spells
are basically identical to all widely available
mana rocks in terms of efficiency, and yet they
are exempt from this divine mana ramp sin tax.
Colors that aren’t green need to live in fear of
wipes eating their mana, whereas green players
don’t unless they make the voluntary choice
to run dorks, which are often better-costed.
Another type of card often considered stax is
rules cards—basically cards that tell opponents
what they can and can’t do. Examples of this
would be Null Rod and Cursed Totem that fully
shut off certain modes of play, as well as
cards like Rule of Law and Aven Mindcensor,
which dramatically restrict the effectiveness of
certain play patterns. These tend to be somewhat
unpopular, since players don’t like being told
what they can’t do, but the awkward thing is that
there are other equally-severe forms of hate
in EDH that players have simply accepted as a
fact of life. When people think of nonbasic hate,
the number one thing they think of is Blood Moon,
a pretty brutal hate piece against decks with
a lot of nonbasic lands. Even more severe is
graveyard hate—most popular graveyard hate
cards exile entire graveyards at a time,
and the most powerful graveyard hate options—which
are reasonably popular cards, mind you—may as well
read “graveyards don’t exist”. This isn’t to
say any of this is unearned, necessarily—EDH’s
nonbasic lands make colorfixing easier than it
should be as long as you’ve got the wallet to
back it up, and the EDH format also has access to
some intensely powerful utility lands. Likewise,
graveyard strategies can get genuinely disgusting
at times, so a lot of powerful hate has been
printed over the years. However, I think a lot of
players would do well to reckon with the fact that
the more powerful graveyard hate options out there
are basically stax pieces, and even a lot of the
less-potent graveyard hate out there exists in a
similar realm. I’d even put a lot of board wipes
into a similar category, particularly ones that
wipe all nonland permanents from a board. These
sorts of cards represent an extreme solution in
a 1v1 format and are costed with those formats
in mind, but this means that when they end
up in formats with more players their effect
is outsized for how much mana they cost. The fact
that Cyclonic Rift is in 28% of blue decks is the
best indicator of this—it was an acceptable answer
at best when I played with it in standard 10 years
ago, but in EDH it’s an absolute haymaker,
setting opponents vastly behind in spent mana.
All of this is to say that stax isn’t some special
type of card. There are cards adjacent to the
things we call stax absolutely everywhere in EDH,
and we accept their existence. It’s often only
the uncommon things that warrant the forehead
scrunches, the sour looks, the “oh, you’re playing
stax?” from the table. Now, is this a defense of
stax necessarily? Well it kind of is—I don’t think
it should be categorized as a wholly unique type
of card as much as it currently is—but to stop
there would be to stop short of asking the more
interesting questions. The most important of these
questions is this—do stax pieces, stax-adjacent
cards, and decks that play a lot of these things
have a positive effect on the EDH format? Well,
the answer to that question is a complicated one,
and it depends a lot on the power level. In cEDH
and the highest reaches of high power casual,
these things are absolutely good tools. cEDH decks
utilize every part of the game to their maximum,
whether that be disgusting graveyard shenanigans,
constant library searching, and frequent turns
with several spells cast in them. Lands and
manafixing alike are also very powerful in
budgetless formats like cEDH, and actually,
a major side effect of Dockside Extortionist
getting banned that I’ve seen cEDH players praise
is that mana hate cards, particularly Blood Moon,
have regained a lot of their former viability
now that there isn’t an easy way around them
via treasures. So yes, high-caliber hate in all
forms will be useful in the highest powers of
commander, and will have a positive effect in
contesting the most powerful proactive decks.
However, at the more middling power levels
that most players play at, these cards don’t
constitute such an unambiguous good. Many of
the heavier-duty stax pieces effectively end
up reading “target opponent gets to putter around
doing barely anything until they draw a removal
spell for this” and is that really positive for
the game? I have a couple friends who would answer
that question with a definite yes—one friend I
asked made the point that playing against an ETB
silencer like Torpor Orb will encourage a Brago
player to diversify their deck. While this isn’t
strictly untrue and while it is a good thing for
players to have more diverse decks, I don’t really
fully buy into this—the only guaranteed fact when
you play a Torpor Orb against a Brago player is
that they’re gonna have a really bad time in this
particular game until the card gets removed—you
have no idea what they’ll do later. I will
always encourage people to build resilient decks,
since these are the decks that will let players
have more fun and will be harder to shut down,
but if you brutalize an unprepared player
with a hard stax piece they almost never see,
the bad time they’ll have isn’t undone by the they
could have been more prepared. Now, I think a lot
of players see this fact and want to draw the
opposite conclusion—that mid-power EDH should be
an unfettered stomp-fest—and unfortunately that’s
an even worse vision for the format. I made an
entire video about why I dislike that version
of mid-power EDH, and I actually think more of
certain types of pressure would be good for EDH
players. So what’s the best way of threading the
needle here? Before I get into that, if you’re
enjoying this video, consider checking out my
Patreon! I’ve been workshopping ideas for this
video for more than three months, and my lovely
Patrons make it possible for me to put in the
effort needed to make deep dives such as this one.
Alright, solutions. Let’s start with the subject
of mass mana hate and boardwipes. As I mentioned,
there’s a certain incongruity to lands being an
untouchable resource while mana rocks and mana
dorks get thrown in the trash, sometimes multiple
times per game. One solution to the question of
wipes is incomplete boardwipes. I dislike Farewell
more than most other cards specifically because
it’s such an absolute wipe—most of the game pieces
present are just immediately put into exile if the
Farewelling player desires it. However, a board
wipe I do like a lot is Cataclysmic Gearhulk. I
run it in my Sharuum Slide deck and it has all
sorts of great attributes there—it’s an artifact
for purposes of reanimation with Sharuum, it’s a
creature with an ETB for purposes of flicker, and
is has two different card types which can allow
the person who played it ample choice on whether
to keep it around or not. The deck can get it out
and trigger it multiple times with relative ease,
but it’s far less polarizing than a lot of removal
engines specifically because it allows players to
keep one permanent of each type. On my side of
the board it gives me interesting setup choices
and opportunities to break parity on it with an
especially potent card, and it’s preferable for my
opponents as well. Despite the card being a board
wipe, my opponents get a sense of agency on what
to do with their board, and even when I flicker
it multiple times it still gives some opportunity
for players to develop a board through it, since
they can “upgrade” the cards they keep around,
effectively. It also punishes players who are
ahead much more than players who are behind,
since a player with two artifacts will only
lose half of them, whereas a player with five
artifacts will lose 80% of them. This idea of an
incomplete boardwipe is also a great solution for
lands—Keldon Firebombers and Urza’s Sylex are
examples of land hate that is less severe than
other land hate specifically because it allows
players to keep around lands. Keeping even three
lands is so much less punishing than keeping
around none at all, as there will be a wide
range of spells in a player’s deck that are still
castable, and players can choose the specific
lands they keep rather than praying to the topdeck
gods to deliver them the correct colors. There are
only these two at the moment as far as I know,
but given that Urza’s Sylex was printed just two
years ago, I can certainly hope that Wizards
of the Coast will revisit this design choice.
Another thing that it would be great to see
more of is soft hate—options for interaction
that are decently powerful but less brutal in
effect. There are a number of cards that cause
nonbasic lands to enter tapped, and these are so
satisfying to me—suddenly the players running the
fancy mana packages are brought back to the level
of me and my friends playing kitchen table magic
in middle school, needing to use taplands to
get more than one color from our lands. The
fact that these can threaten a double-hit on the
most powerful fixing in commander, fetchlands,
is especially nice. I don’t get much joy out
of seeing players get mana screwed by powerful
nonbasic hate, but I love to see them join the
tapland gang. For graveyard hate, this could look
like pinpoint exilers such as Emperor of Bones
or Pit of Offerings, and it could also look like
shuffle effects such as Endurance. I want to see
additional powerful shuffle-into-library effects
be printed as a graveyard hate options—it’s
equally effective in the short term without
posing such a dramatic and final punishment for
the graveyard enjoyer, and has added utility in
being able to shuffle one’s own graveyard as well.
Aside from soft hate, a good option for mid-power
stax in the here and now are some of the softer
general-purpose stax pieces that already exist,
with the two key ones being tax cards and rule of
law effects. Tax cards like Thorn of Amethyst make
spells more expensive, most often noncreature
spells, and these are nice because they’re
not too hard to break parity on, and they also
impact players who are ahead and thus casting
more spells much more than they impact players
who are behind. The same is true for rule of
law effects—though capping the number of spells a
player can cast each turn at 1 is a more dramatic
effect and will make opponents unhappy at times,
they likewise punish players who are ahead more
than players who are behind. In addition, since
basically all of these are symmetrical and require
a bit of effort to break parity on, they’re much
more fair than a lot of other options for stax.
My Liesa deck features a number of these sorts
of softer stax pieces, and though I’d place the
deck on the upper end of mid-power, it can play
decently at both mid and high powers because all
of the tools in the deck disproportionately hit
more powerful decks, and especially combo decks.
My Liesa deck also features the final form of stax
I find especially appropriate in mid-powers—Slug
Effects. A major critique of Stax cards that I
mentioned about 20 minutes ago is that they limit
player agency, and slug stax cards subvert this
by forcing players to pay with a resource that is,
by default, quite plentiful in commander—life
total. Liesa is such a fantastic creature because
her effect punishes players who play a lot of
spells more heavily and fully prevents combos
that require casting a spell an arbitrarily
large number of times, but it accomplishes
these things through the vector of life total.
This means that stax decks, traditionally a more
controlling strategy, can take on new life
as a beatdown strategy, forcing opponents to
make hard choices about whether to do the plays
they want to and face life total consequences,
or whether to keep their life total at a more safe
level and hold back on their power plays. Liesa
and Rug of Smothering are examples of cards that
cause players to lose life for each spell cast,
but there are also cards that deal damage to
players for their nonbasic lands, cards that
deal damage to players for their creature counts,
cards that deal damage to players for attacking
in certain ways, cards that deal damage to players
for drawing cards, Blood Artist effects to punish
sacrifice-oriented strategies, and so on. I highly
recommend including these in aggressive decks,
as they allow for a sort of stax-aggro blend
that makes for some really cool gameplay and
puts the pressure on opposing decision making
without needing to flat-out tell them no.
EDH doesn’t necessarily benefit from people
getting fully locked out or made miserable,
but a format with a greater amount of soft stax
and soft hate has a lot of benefits. It encourages
more resilient, well-rounded decks. It pushes
players toward thinking about their opponents,
both during games and during deckbuilding. A
format where everybody brings their solitaire
pile to play against three other solitaire
piles isn’t a good one, and anything that
pushes people into considering their opponents
more heavily is a good thing. Players should
feel pressured by what opponents are doing, but
they shouldn’t necessarily feel oppressed. Stax
effects that loop in life loss in some way are
good specifically because they pressure opponents
while maintaining player agency. More soft stax
will also reduce the height of the format—the
battlecruiser version of EDH does appeal to
a lot of people, and I do get the appeal,
but there are elements of it that we’d
be well-served to curtail a bit. It’s not
good when boards are filled up with endless
permanents that nobody wants to keep track
of, when turns take 5-10 minutes each,
and where frequent full-board wipes are
a necessary fact of life. I’m not saying that
this is a form of EDH that needs to die off
or that nobody enjoys it, but it shouldn’t
be the default as much as it is currently.
Some of what I’m suggesting here is
ways players can change their own decks,
but a lot of it comes down to Wizards of the Coast
since they control what cards are printed, as well
as the commander format as a whole now. Only time
will tell what exactly they have in store for EDH,
but there are some promising indicators. The
sorts of soft hate cards I want to see more of
are being printed—Magebane Lizard, Emperor
of Bones, Aven Interruptor, Sunspine Lynx,
and High Noon are a handful of designs I really
like from this year, and there are others like
Urza’s Sylex and Rug of Smothering from recent
past years that are likewise good signs of things
to come. The Valgavoth deck also serves as a
notable milestone in precon design—the fact
that Wizards of the Coast felt comfortable making
a group slug deck full of the sort of damage-stax
I mentioned earlier is cool and makes me
curious about what’s to come. We’ve also
seen a gradual increase in stax effects being
stapled to cards with another primary purpose,
such as in the case of Boromir Warden of the
Tower. The stax cards of yore—Tabernacle,
Winter Orb, Armageddon, Overburden—these
aren’t going to be the future of the game,
nor should they be. Hard stax provides a
fun tool for the power gamers out there,
but EDH isn’t going to be improved by putting a
bunch of battlecruiser players through a trial
by fire of the nastiest permanents that have
ever been printed. This format will be at its
most vibrant when it can find a balance between
player agency and interactivity between players,
where players can do their own thing but
where that thing might need to take into
account the actions of opponents, might have to
navigate some challenges here and there. And,
things we might call stax have a valid role
to play in cultivating that sort of format.
Thanks for making it to the end! And thanks to
Archidekt for supporting the channel. Archidekt
recently had a major UI update, and I’ve been
enjoying the increased flexibility of the visual
display as well as the extra analysis tools.
A link to my decks is down in the description.
Additional thanks to my patrons, some of whom
are on screen now. If you want to join them,
a link to my patreon is down in the description.
Earlier today I uploaded some thoughts about the
announcement last week—it’s not something I
feel strongly enough about to want to make a
public video yet, but if you want my thoughts
that’s where you can find them. Alternatively,
if you want some different thoughts of mine
without paying me money, I was on the Magic
Mirror Podcast with 3/3 Elk last week, and a link
to that is in the description. Alright, bye now.